what's going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have a lot
of exciting news to go over we have some
deadpool 3 news and some guardians of
the galaxy casting news and info
deadline has released an article about
an actress joining the cast and crew of
the guardians team and in true james
gunn fashion he took to twitter to
confirm this and deadpool 3 gets a very
very exciting update and there's even a
tiny little bit of a teaser that another
mcu actor could be appearing in deadpool
3 now hopefully a lot of mcu actors make
cameos in deadpool 3 maybe it could be
how we actually thought multiverse of
madness was going to be just a ton of
cameos all throughout the movie but this
one hinted at actor i would actually
really love to see interact with
deadpool because i think it would be
extremely funny to see and i actually
think it would be really funny to see
this character behave in a rated r way
because we're talking about the god of
thunder thor so exciting things to talk
about today let's dive into it and of
course if you're new be sure to
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest videos so over the past
week deadpool has gotten a few really
exciting updates now in case you didn't
know ryan reynolds recently took a
little hiatus from acting and directing
and a lot of people kind of freaked out
because they thought that ryan reynolds
was putting deadpool 3 on hold however
he has confirmed that he has been
working on the script the entire time
one of the great things about deadpool
coming to the mcu is that ryan reynolds
worked it out with kevin feige to where
they can both produce the movie and
where ryan reynolds can actually have a
really really big say on everything that
happens now of course he had a lot to
say about what happened in the first two
but he has even more creative control
now and now he's working with the big
dog kevin feige who of course is
brilliant so i'm expecting the best
deadpool film that we've gotten yet now
ryan reynolds has been working on the
script for a very very long time but the
deadpool team recently got new writers
for the script as well and here's where
things actually kind of get interesting
now the original writers who were
helping ryan reynolds write the script
were the malino sisters who were the
writers for bob's burgers and they did a
lot to the first edition of the script
however now there are two new writers
attached rhett reese and paul wernick
and the way they talk about the script
makes it sound like there's a lot of
really exciting things going to go down
in deadpool 3 because they talk about
how secretive the script is in an
interview with den of geek they were
asked about if they were using elements
from the previous drafts of the script
written by the molino sisters in which
they responded by saying they have an
answer but they're really not supposed
to divulge any plot details now they
said that jokingly and then they
continued to kind of joke and said they
are working in a secret vault under an
ocean somewhere implying that everything
that is going down with deadpool 3 is a
very huge secret now i've pitched before
what i think would be an amazing plot
for deadpool 3. it would be hilarious
and just have an insane amount of cameos
and i'll talk about that in just a sec
but here's where things get kind of
exciting on the forefront rhett reese
and paul wernick recently collaborated
with thor on a netflix film spider-head
so in an interview with den of geek they
asked the two writers if thor could be
making an appearance in ryan reynolds
film if we could get a deadpool and thor
interaction and here's what they
responded with rhys said that it would
be super cool but if he did they
certainly couldn't talk about it now of
course this is in no way a confirmation
that thor is going to be in deadpool 3.
however i do think that we are going to
get an insane amount of cameos in
deadpool 3 because i think deadpool 3 is
going to be a story about how he goes
from the fox universe to the mcu you
almost have to go this route with a
character like deadpool because he is so
aware of the actual reality of the
movies deadpool breaks the fourth wall
that's one of the most exciting things
about deadpool he can address what the
audience is actually thinking he doesn't
just live inside of the boundaries of
the film and we know that he's going to
be in the mcu but he's gotta get out of
the fox universe first and the way i
hope he does that and i've mentioned
this before is i hope they do a deadpool
kills the fox universe storyline to
where he just completely kills every
single person in the fox universe and
makes it to where they can all now be in
the mcu obviously it would be their
variance and he would address this in a
fourth wall breaking type of way but i
think it would be really really funny if
that's how he actually got to the mcu
and kind of wanted to keep the mcu2
himself that's why he would kill
everybody else now if you're wondering
about deadpool being rated r over at
marvel studios and disney i understand
your concern it was my concern as well
that disney would not allow deadpool to
remain rated r however it appears we
have absolutely nothing to worry about
in that same interview with den of geek
the writers were asked if disney was
going to kind of make them behave and
play pg-13 or would they be allowed to
remain rated r in which they replied
that the studio has actually been very
supportive of the characters rated r
requirements they said in the interview
they've been very supportive with regard
to that now when it comes to a
particular joke if we cross a line maybe
we'll hear at some point maybe not that
joke but i think they've been incredibly
supportive of what we're doing because
obviously we were doing it separate from
them for a long time and i think they've
seen the success and they've had their
own even greater success so hopefully
it'll be a marriage made in heaven but
we've definitely got their support and
that's a great thing to feel so it looks
like deadpool is in fact remaining rated
r and this is coming directly from the
writers themselves however it does look
like kevin feige does have a line and he
might make them rewrite some of the
jokes that they have but if there's
anybody that i have confidence in it's
kevin feige now as far as some guardians
of the galaxy 3 news we have a new cast
member deadline has reported an
exclusive that oscar nominee maria
bakalova has joined the cast of
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 in a key
role now unfortunately they did not
reveal what role this is going to be
however like i mentioned in true james
gunn fashion he went to twitter and did
confirm that she is in fact part of the
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 cast he
replied to deadline's tweet saying yes
yes yes okay i guess i should be
surprised it took you guys this long to
get this one maria baklava is incredible
hashtag guardians of the galaxy vol 3.
so now of course the question is who is
she going to be playing and let's dive
into a little bit about what we know so
far about guardians 3 and if you're
trying to avoid any type of spoilers for
guardians 3 here's your warning although
they're not particularly huge but we
will be talking about the villain the
villain is pretty much confirmed to be
the high evolutionary we have speculated
about this for a while and then some
photos got released from the paparazzi
that showed a bunch of animal alien
looking people and what these are are
experiments done on animals to make them
kind of humanoid by the high
evolutionary that's exactly what the
high evolutionary does in fact he is the
one who created rocket raccoon and it's
widely believed that these evolved
animals who are humanoids are going to
be living on counter-earth a planet that
the high evolutionary creates in the
comics that mimics earth but instead of
humans it has all of his experiments his
evolved animals so it's possible that
maria could be playing somebody related
to the high evolutionary or she could
even be playing one of these evolved
animal species but keep in mind deadline
said she is playing a key role now she
could be playing somebody that is a part
of the sovereign and i think that the
sovereign actually works for the high
evolutionary because if you think about
it it just makes sense they are all
about evolution just like the high
evolutionary is so she could be playing
a council member of the sovereign in the
post-credit scene of guardians 2 aisha
is told that the council is waiting for
her and she replies with they are
perturbed that she has wasted their
resources so perhaps maria is going to
be a part of the council that addresses
aisha now at the same time she could be
playing some type of a superhero i think
it would be really cool if they
introduced even more heroes in guardians
3 especially since this is the end for
most of the guardians but i'm pretty
confident that the actual guardians of
the galaxy team is going to be a
permanent thing in the mcu however the
members will swap in and out so she
could be a new hero joining the mcu
we'll have to wait and see but let me
know your best guess in the comments
down below be sure to let me know what
you think about all the latest news
don't forget to like the video and of
course subscribe so you can stay up to
date on all the latest mcu news and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you